フライパンっていうのは熱を通します ih とガスコンロでパって炎が出てるところ
にこれを置いて熱がこの金属に伝わってくらい板全体が熱くねそう言ってフライパンは
このヶ月することができますで今回この原理を使いますちょっととある実験をして
みようと思いまして裁判をちょっとなるべく買ってみましたこれはいいサイズだな
は多さでおしゃれ
で今回金で他のフライパンの熱の伝わり方はどこまで強いかと気になったので例えば
ですよ2のフライパンで恋前列で熱心でてここにものを普通に焼けるのは彼ここにその
くらいするものを降りたぞ3ターンに重ねて見つめほどしたらフライパンからスターて
こっちのフライパンまでやってるぜなるとこっちのくらいかなーものがフライできる
ここでここでもの
フライしたこのフライパンの上からにライブを重ねるどっちでもそれにものがフライで
キザにここにものん
the river ああ
とりあえずちょっと何が言いたいかというとぐらいバーナー目にフライパンを重ねて
そのフラッパーがあったかったさらにそのフライパンの上に物を置いてさらにその
フライパンにフライパンを置いてそのフライパンの上にも動いて阻止フライパン
大皿に置いてそこでもまたものがやってるっていうね愛でをに一見いろんなものを
くらいできるという現象が出る僕が考えたわけです
ブーバパパスパーンっ
と2つだっつっスタッフとあったカーリーフライバー行ってもハズレならのわかってる
んで
まず加熱していきましょう背景が点火しました
購入後たらフライパンを乗せていく見てらっしゃい付箋にっ子だったらここだけが厚く
ないもう
もう誰が膨大だもうだめ他の人に水を入れてもこれが食べて蒸発しますよ
これはわかりますか水を入れたらもうあんなことになっちゃいますこの熱い声パニ
サーンいくら今犯されていましょう3個目
3個目4米後米ロックなっ比90ず11だ街へ
自分にこれでラフなはいというわけでこんな感じになりました今回気になって本当に
これが熱通してプライパンで上に伝わるかどうかでございますフライパン自身の熱の
伝わり方
そしてプライパン自身から発する熱自身立電動とフライパン地震が発生
られる熱で話しフライパンでじゃあどこまでも居座るから本番の日ところでございます
もうちょっと目してみましょう
これまずでわかんねーなーこれ本当な分で微妙なところだと思いますあのフライバー2
枚目3枚目はついのまつげないんだけども上まで来ると熱いかかってるかわかんない
快適な十分で時間起きましたただしてフライパンのどこまで熱が伝わるのか実際に僕の
連れで試したいと思います
すべて試したいと思いますはーい
4会やります今日はみきぽんです
iphone なみきぽんですあえて今日はねみきぽんチャンネルやっていこうとダメ
ですよ
びっくりしたまず1番目12枚目でございます
車
バーン
暑くないまあまあねたてるねちょっと歳でプレイパンといってもずうに前の熱を使う
ことはないということが分かりました
お作りします通知の意味ですああ
償いズーマでイキますっ air
暑くないん
これ略装しずらいの究明
ちょっと嫌な予感がしたそろそろやばいかを立ち上げます
パーン
あっはぁ次だ
たぶん次次はちょっと暑いちょっと暑いちゃったぜ長い目ですそろそろヤバイ気がして
きました
バーン
反発
絶対熱いよ
バーンじゃああーちなみに5枚目はどうなんだろう
ua お前が本当にやばいごめんやればいい
ぱっちょちょっとまっちゃったぞ
あっ本当に売ってるんだからほんとです
これは
います
e 7